Stable salt is built on stable partition, is built on rotate, is built on reverse, is built on itter swap, right? Range swap. It's abstractions all the way down. And when you get to the bottom, the abstraction, you know, the complexity disappears. So let's take a step back here because I feel like my ice cream sandwich for lunch was not substantial enough food for my brain to operate at the level that yours is operating at right now. Well, the meaning is what we give it, right? Ultimately, we build things, hopefully to make the world a better place. But if these kind of quality ideas are important to us, then these ideas should come along for the ride
稳定的盐建立在稳定的分区之上，建立在旋转之上，建立在反转之上，建立在迭代交换之上，对吧？范围交换。这全都是抽象。当你到达底部时，抽象，你知道的，复杂性就消失了。所以让我们在这里退一步，因为我觉得我午餐吃的冰淇淋三明治不够充饥，无法让我的大脑以你现在正在运转的水平来思考。嗯，意义是我们赋予它的，对吧？最终，我们构建东西，希望让世界变得更美好。但是，如果这些高质量的想法对我们很重要，那么这些想法就应该顺理成章地融入其中
and should be the way we think about things, I think. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 288 recorded on May 27, 2006. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben. We chat about the most recent C++ now, lasting software quality, programming as theory building, and more. We are back. Well, actually, should we talk about? I was about, I was about to say we're back.
并且应该成为我们思考事物的方式，我是这么认为的。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，我是第 288 期，录制于 2006 年 5 月 27 日。我的名字是康纳（Connor），今天与我的共同主持是本（Ben）。我们聊了聊最近的 C++ Now、持久的软件质量、作为理论构建的编程等等。我们回来了。嗯，其实，我们该聊聊吗？我正要，我正要说我们回来了。
Should we talk about what we're going to talk about? Is this the open, though? Maybe this is the open. Well, yeah. I mean, for the, for the listener, we were just chatting for the last 20 plus minutes because Ben was eating his lunch. I was eating an ice cream sandwich because I had no time to prepare lunch. And now, now we hit the record button.
我们该聊聊我们要聊什么吗？不过，这是开场白吗？也许这就是开场白。好吧，是的。我的意思是，对于听众来说，我们刚刚聊了过去的 20 多分钟，因为本在吃午饭。我吃了一个冰淇淋三明治，因为我没有时间准备午餐。现在，现在我们按下了录音键。
And we got to figure out what we're going to talk about because we don't have any necessarily pre, what do you call them? Lined up topics. Anyways, listen. You may leave comments on the GitHub discussion for episode 289 if you can hear the creaks of Ben's headphones, and we will address in future conversations. Is that when we are after 289?
我们得想想要聊些什么，因为我们没有necessarily pre，你们叫什么来着？排好的主题。总之，听着。如果你能听到本的耳机发出的吱吱声，你可以在第 289 期的 GitHub 讨论中留言，我们将在以后的对话中解决这个问题。那是我们在第 289 期之后吗？
I think so. Maybe it's 288. I might have an off-by-one error. Let me check. It is episode 288. I was off-by-one. So we're closing in on 300 episodes. Five years straight.
我想是的。也许是第 288 期。我可能犯了一个差一错误（off-by-one error）。让我查一下。这就是第 288 期。我差了一个。所以我们正在接近 300 期。整整五年。
We haven't missed a week yet. I have been thinking when the baby comes how that's going to work. Oh, yeah. We might just have to record a couple. I'm going to have to queue up like at least a month, if not two months. I mean, sometimes already like a single conversation gets cut into four episodes, which is a month right there. So I think like two months should give me enough wiggle room. I would say two months is a good thing to shoot for.
我们一期都没有落下。我一直在想，当孩子出生时，这会怎么运作。哦，是的。我们可能只需要录制几期。我得排队准备至少一个月，甚至两个月的量。我的意思是，有时候仅仅一个对话就会被剪成四期，这就已经是一个月了。所以我觉得两个月应该能给我足够的腾挪空间。我会说两个月是一个很好的目标。
Definitely the first month, expect to be very sleep deprived. It's just how it goes. That's the number one piece of, not advice or feedback, but just the number one thing people do, tell me that that first month. Just the fact. The baby is waking up every couple hours. And admittedly, between Shima and I, I operate much better on less sleep. And I've done it before.
绝对是第一个月，预计会极度缺觉。事情就是这样。这不是建议或反馈，但这绝对是人们告诉我的关于第一个月的第一大事情。这就是事实。宝宝每隔几个小时就会醒来。诚实地说，在我和希玛（Shima）之间，我在睡眠较少的情况下运作得要好得多。而且我以前也这样做过。
She does not. So it's going to be interesting. Like, as soon as she's like less than seven hours a night, she is pining for more sleep. So it shall be an adventure. Yeah. Well, you go to sleep when the baby sleeps, I think. That's what people say. That's kind of what you have to do.
她则不然。所以这会很有趣。比如，只要她一晚睡少于七小时，她就会渴望更多的睡眠。所以这将会是一次冒险。是的。嗯，宝宝睡你跟着睡，我想。人们都是这么说的。这基本上就是你必须做的。
Yeah. And the baby only sleeps. Two hours at the time, usually, sort of thing. Fingers crossed that we get one of those babies that just very quickly, I have a number of friends and one sibling that have kids, and I guess extended family through Shima that have kids. And I've heard varying different stories. Some babies, you know, are much better sleepers, much more soon.
是的。而且宝宝通常一次只睡两个小时左右。祈祷我们能遇到那种很快就能睡整觉的宝宝吧，我有一些朋友和一个有孩子的兄弟姐妹，还有通过希玛认识的有孩子的远房亲戚。我听到了各种不同的说法。有些宝宝，你知道的，睡得好得多，也更快。
Others are not. It's, what do you call it, toss of the dice, what you end up with? Yeah. Yeah, my youngest didn't sleep through the night until he was, I think a year old. That's a long. That's a long time. So get used to get used to the small hours.
另一些则不然。这叫什么来着，碰运气，看你摊上哪种？是的。是的，我的小儿子直到我想大概一岁时才睡整觉。那是很长的时间。那是一段很长的时间。所以习惯吧，习惯那些凌晨的时刻。
I used to watch, I used to my oldest, I used to have him on a pillow and I used to be on the couch and I was doing the feeding in the middle of the night and I would watch reruns of Daltrek Next Generation because that was the only good thing that was on at like 2 a.m. or 3am
我以前看，我以前把我的老大放在枕头上，我以前在沙发上，我在半夜喂奶，我会看《星际迷航：下一代》（Star Trek: Next Generation）的重播，因为那是凌晨 2 点或 3 点时唯一好看的节目
or whenever it was. Oh yeah, this must have been pre, like YouTube pre-streaming. YouTube was YouTube was around, but it was in the very early days. Yeah, I'm talking like 2006, right? Yeah. Oh, that's like right when it didn't, when did YouTube start? I think 2005 it launched.
或者无论什么时候。哦，对，这一定是在 YouTube 出现之前，流媒体出现之前。YouTube 当时已经存在了，但还在非常早期的阶段。对，我说的是 2006 年左右，对吧？是的。哦，那就像是正当，YouTube 是什么时候开始的？我想是 2005 年推出的。
I was going to say, that's like right, right when it, there must have just been like a couple cat videos on YouTube at that point. And the elephant video and, yeah, some cat videos. Wow. Yeah, I didn't actually, I've actually been concerned. That's, well, not that I'm actually concerned about it. I guess we'll start talking about something tech related in a minute. But I've been thinking, because I consume.
我正要说，那就像是正正当好，当时 YouTube 上肯定只有几段猫咪视频。还有大象视频，还有，嗯，一些猫咪视频。哇。是的，我其实没有，我其实一直很担心。那是，嗯，倒不是说我真的为此担心。我想我们过一会儿就会开始谈论一些与技术相关的话题了。但我一直在想，因为我消耗了
so much podcast content and audiobooks in between. And the time to consume that is going to evaporate. But if you're telling me that while you're feeding the baby, I guess in the first few months, it's not like you're having a conversation with the kid while the kid's feeding. You have to entertain yourself. Maybe that is the opportune. Maybe I'll be chomping at the bit, you know,
如此多的播客内容和有声书。而消耗这些的时间将会蒸发。但如果你告诉我，当你喂宝宝时，我想在最初的几个月里，这并不像你在喂孩子的时候跟孩子聊天。你必须自己找乐子。也许这是一个绝佳的时机。也许我会跃跃欲试，你知道的，
for the 3 a.m. feeding when my wife's trying to sleep. Maybe I'll be thinking like, thank God. Like, I haven't been able to listen to the most recent, I don't know, insert my favorite podcast, co-recursive. Well, what is my favorite podcast right now? I don't know. Anyways, enough baby talk. Well, you have that ahead of you. Yeah.
为了妻子试图睡觉时的凌晨 3 点喂奶。也许我会觉得谢天谢地。比如，我一直没能听最近的，我不知道，插入我最喜欢的播客，Co-Recursive。嗯，我现在最喜欢的播客是什么？我不知道。不管怎样，婴儿的话题就到此为止吧。嗯，你前面还有这关要过。是的。
Stay tuned, listener for, I don't know, what do you call it? Parent Corner coming into a podcast near you. Your Parent Corner. Yeah, late 2027. But I promise I won't disappear. You know, there's a podcast I listen to called Tomorrow. FM or something like that. It's hosted by two front-end web devs, Dax and some other guy.
敬请期待，听众朋友们，我不知道，这叫什么来着？即将在离你最近的播客中登场的“父母角落”（Parent Corner）。你的“父母角落”。是的，2007 年末。但我保证我不会消失。你知道的，我听过一个叫 Tomorrow.FM 左右的播客。它由两个前端网络开发者主持，Dax 和另外一个人。
And I think one of them was having a kid. And then as soon as the kid showed up, they haven't posted a podcast for like months, which I keep waiting for like the come, like the return to the podcast to hear. Because he was saying leading up to it that everyone was telling him and was going to be really difficult. And he said, I really hope that this is just like another thing that's like way easier for me than it is for other people so that he could come back and be like, I knew it was not going to be that hard, but we've never gotten the update on that.
我想他们其中一个有了孩子。然后孩子一出生，他们已经好几个月没发播客了，我一直在等他们回归播客，想听听看。因为他在那之前说，每个人都告诉他这将会非常困难。他说，我真的希望这只是像其他事情一样，对我来说比对其他人要容易得多，这样他就可以回来并说，我早就知道没那么难，但我们从来没有得到这方面的最新消息。
Anyways, what are our topics for today? Is there anything at top of mind that you'd like to chat about? What have you been up to since we last spoke? Of course, I went to C++ now, so we could talk some about that. Oh, yeah, I totally forgot that I also went to... And you went to NDC Toronto. I went to NDC Toronto, the inaugural edition of that version of it, but technically the fifth edition of what was formerly...
不管怎样，我们今天的主题是什么？有什么你想聊的头条话题吗？自从我们上次交谈以来你一直在忙什么？当然，我去了 C++ Now，所以我们可以聊聊那个。哦，对，我完全忘了我也去了……而且你去了多伦多 NDC。我去了多伦多 NDC，那是该版本的第一届，但技术上是以前被称为……
formerly CPP North. Sure, that's a great topic for at least our first episode. How was C++ now? I recall looking at the program and I definitely noted a couple talks that I wanted to see. And I know you were giving a talk that I have long wanted to see that was never recorded before. And it's not available online, but should be at some point in the future, correct? Yeah, it was recorded in Aspen. So to answer your first question, it was great. really good conference as always. It just feels like, you know, it's like a holiday because you're going to Aspen.
以前被称为 CPP North 的第五届。当然，这至少是我们第一期节目的绝佳主题。C++ Now 怎么样？我记得看过节目单，我确实注意到有几个我想看的演讲。我知道你做了一个我一直想看但以前从未被录制过的演讲。它现在不在网上，但在未来的某个时候应该会发布，对吧？是的，它在阿斯彭（Aspen）录制了。所以回答你的第一个问题，它很棒。一如既往是一个非常好的会议。感觉就像是，你知道的，就像是一个假期，因为你要去阿斯彭。
It's a beautiful place and you're going to see friends who you've met there, many of whom now I've known for a decade and have become friends. And you're getting to talk about like the sort of, I don't know how to describe it, the high level stuff of engineering. Like you're getting to talk about topics that you don't. don't typically get to talk about in your day-to-day job, with your co-workers, you get to talk at a different level with people who understand different things. And you get to learn a lot.
那是个美丽的地方，你要去见你在那里认识的朋友，他们中的许多人现在我认识已经有十年了，并成为了朋友。而且你可以谈论，我不知道该怎么形容，工程学的高级内容。比如你可以谈论那些你在日常工作中、与同事们通常不会谈论的话题，你可以与那些理解不同事物的人在不同的层面上交流。而且你能学到很多东西。
You get to learn a lot. Yeah. Yeah, C++ Now was actually my first conference ever back in 2019. Right. Yeah, it was fantastic. You know, like you said, you're the type of person that goes to a conference in general, let alone C++ now is you're with like-minded folks when you are there. Yeah, and it's not that it's a different, it's a different vibe.
你能学到很多东西。是的。是的，早在 2019 年，C++ Now 其实是我参加过的第一个会议。没错。是的，太棒了。你知道的，就像你说的，会去参加会议的人，更不用说 C++ Now 了，当你去那里时，你和志同道合的人在一起。是的，并不是说它是一个不同的，它是一种不同的氛围。
It's not just like, it's not like you work with people who are, who are not intelligent, right? But it's just like when you're in the day-to-day, you can't sort of stick your head up and getting a break, getting a go to a conference and just step away from work. It's really important, I think, to be able to do that. and just just kind of broaden your perspective a bit yeah yeah absolutely so what were the I mean I brought the schedule up but you know
它不只是，它不像是你和那些不聪明的人一起工作，对吧？但就像你在日常生活中一样，你不能把头抬起来休息一下，去参加一个会议，从工作中抽身出来。我认为，能够做到这一点并且稍微拓宽一下你的视角，真的非常重要。是的，是的，绝对的。那么，有哪些，我的意思是，我把日程表调出来了，但是呢
it would be very boring for me to scroll through and be like oh tell me about this so what were the sure sure you remember what were the highlights of the talks that you went to see obviously you couldn't see all of them and then also I don't know what order you want to do how did your talk well let's see let's I've got the schedule here too let me just check the keynotes to begin with
让我滚动浏览并说“哦，跟我讲讲这个”会非常无聊，所以有哪些，当然，当然，你还记得你去听的演讲的亮点是什么吗？显然你不可能看完所有的演讲，而且我也不知道你想按什么顺序来，你的演讲怎么样？好吧，让我们看看，我也把日程表拿出来了，让我先看看主题演讲。
yeah I mean so Barry Reveson gave the first keynote, and I think that was a really good one. It was about reflection. He's given several talks on reflection now. This was another, I think, basically, you know, he's a really good speaker. He knows that he knows all about reflection, and it was a really good opening keynote. Aside from that, the talks which stood out to me, there were some slots where I couldn't decide which talk to go to, which is always the case, a little bit frustrating. but you just have to wait for the videos to come out.
是的，我是说，巴里·雷维森（Barry Revzin）发表了第一场主题演讲，我认为那是一场非常精彩的演讲。它是关于反射的。他现在已经发表了好几次关于反射的演讲了。这是另一个，我想，基本上，你知道的，他是一个非常优秀的演讲者。他知道他非常了解反射，这是一个非常好的开幕主题演讲。除此之外，令我瞩目的演讲有那么几个时段我无法决定去听哪一个，这总是不可避免的，有点令人沮丧。但你只需要等待视频发布就行了。
I really liked Rob Layhe's talk, or actually he gave us a double-slot talk, about using senders at sort of the lowest level. I forget the name of the talk. You have it up there? Towards async everything, part one and part two. Yeah. So he really presented a cut,
我非常喜欢罗布·莱希（Rob Layhe）的演讲，或者其实他给我们做了一个双时段的演讲，关于在最低级别使用发送者（senders）。我忘了演讲的名字了。你把它打开了吗？走向异步的一切，第一部分和第二部分。是的。所以他真的呈现了一场连续的，
like I say, back-to-back talks, which actually stand-alone, but one also leads it into the other, right? And he was talking about using senders to drive the sort of lowest-level, OS-level mechanisms of asynchronous I-O. So I-O-U-ring. That was really good. And I definitely want to see those talks again when they come out on video. There was a lot of information in there.
就像我说的，背靠背的演讲，它们实际上是独立的，但其中一个也引出了另一个，对吧？他谈到了使用发送者来驱动异步 I/O 的最低级别、操作系统级别的机制。也就是 I/O-uring。那真的很棒。当视频发布时，我绝对想再次观看这些演讲。里面有很多信息。
Rob is an extremely polished speaker. Yeah, he has a background in theater or some kind of speaking, which, came up, we interviewed him once while we were walking in Venice after having like a couple glasses of wine. And I could not get over how like you seem like he'd been preparing for this moment his entire life. And I was like, how are you more composed than like some other folks we have interviewed? And I think you mentioned that, yeah, he used to do some kind of theater or what do you call it, not Toastmasters, but I have to have to look it up what he did. Something like that. He's a very, very polished presenter.
罗布是一位极其老练的演讲者。是的，他有戏剧背景或某种演讲背景，这一点，我们在威尼斯散步时采访过他一次，当时我们喝了幾杯葡萄酒。我简直无法忘怀，你看上去就像他为这一刻准备了一生。我说，你怎么比我们采访过的一些其他人还要镇定？我想你提到过，是的，他过去常常做某种戏剧或者叫什么来着，不是 Toastmasters，但我得查查他做过什么。类似那样的。他是一个非常、非常老练的演讲者。
So I thought his talks were great. I also thought Michael Case's talk was one that I've been waiting for for a while. It's called lasting quality. And he talked about the idea of structural quality in code. So this is to be contrasted with, so the kind of quality that we're used to is, we might say one pillar is functional quality, right? So that's things like, does the code? meet the specification? Is it, you know, is it, is it, is it bug free as far as we can make it? Does it,
所以我认为他的演讲棒极了。我也认为迈克尔·凯斯（Michael Case）的演讲是我期待了一段时间的演讲。它叫做持久的质量（lasting quality）。他谈到了代码中结构质量的概念。所以这与以下内容形成对比，我们习惯的质量种类是，我们可以说一个支柱是功能质量，对吧？所以那是诸如之类的事情，代码是否符合规范？它是不是，你知道的，它是不是，它是不是在我们能做到的范围内没有漏洞？它是不是，
does it perform well? These are functional, this is functional quality, right? And then another pillar of quality is process quality. And this is like, can we deliver on time? Can we repeatedly perform this for the organization without the team burning out? You know, this is a process quality is a kind of a team thing and an execution thing, right? And then, and both of those, things functional quality and process quality they tend to be you know they're the things we can measure basically and so they get measured right and so they get used the third pillar structural quality is actually the most important and the one that is least measurable and therefore the one that is least talked about or measured in organizations but if you have
它的性能好不好？这些是功能性的，这就是功能质量，对吧？然后质量的另一个支柱是过程质量。这就像是，我们能按时交付吗？我们能否为组织重复执行此操作而不会导致团队精疲力竭？你知道的，这是一种过程质量，是一件团队的事情和执行的事情，对吧？然后，这两者，功能质量和过程质量，它们往往是，你知道的，它们是我们能够衡量的事情，因此它们得到了衡量，所以它们被使用。第三个支柱，结构质量，实际上是最重要的，也是最不可衡量的，因此也是组织中最少被谈论或衡量的，但如果你拥有
structural quality the other two kind of naturally flow from it there is a prerequisite for the I do. And structural quality is things like, you know, things that we, when we say code is beautiful, we have, we, we know what we see, right? We know, we know when we see beautiful code and that beautiful code is, has good structural quality. And it's things like, is it maintainable, is it testable? Is it efficient, right? Is it in there? But it's more of these intangible things or somewhat less tangible things than the other measurable parts. How nice is the code to work, in a sense of, you know, does changing one part cause ripple effects through other parts? Is it compartmentalized?
结构质量，其他两项就会自然而然地随之产生，这是……的前提。结构质量是诸如，你知道的，当我们说代码很美时，我们拥有，我们，我们知道我们看到了什么，对吧？我们知道，当我们看到优美的代码时我们知道，并且那优美的代码具有良好的结构质量。它是诸如，它是否易于维护，是否易于测试？它是否高效，对吧？它在里面吗？但这些是比其他可测量部分更无形或稍微不太具体的东西。代码用起来有多爽，从某种意义上说，你知道的，更改一部分是否会引起其他部分的连锁反应？它是被划分开的吗？
Is it abstracted and composed and things like that? These are things that is much harder to measure, right, in a quantitative way. But structural quality is, you know, if you don't have that, everything else is worse. And if you have that, everything else is better. Yeah, that sounds like a very interesting talk. And definitely, yeah, I don't. know. I mean, I was thinking if you tried to measure that stuff, like, is it possible? I know that Klang-Tidy has a, like, complexity heuristic of, like, based on the nestedness of stuff, but that
它被抽象和组合了吗诸如此类？这些是更难用定量的方式去衡量的事情，对吧？但结构质量是，你知道的，如果你没有那个，其他一切都会变糟。如果你拥有那个，其他一切都会变好。是的，听起来这是一个非常有趣的演讲。而且绝对的，是的，我不知道。我的意思是，我在想如果你试图去衡量那些东西，比如，这可能吗？我知道 Clang-Tidy 有一个类似复杂性启发式的东西，比如基于东西的嵌套程度，但这
doesn't really capture, like, there's definitely, like, if you design something, I remember one time early in my career, there was, like, report system within the software that we had, and you could add these, what were called category reports. Shout out to anybody that works on the Axis software system. And I remember at one point I had to add like a nested category report. I don't know if the code was good at the time because I was so early in my career. But I remember I knew I was going to have to do this like multiple times with multiple reports. So I did it in such a way that like I did a ton of upfront work in order with the like not just to hack this one thing in, but like with keeping in mind I was going to have to do this a bunch of times. So it was a ton of work the first time.
并不能真正捕捉到，绝对有，比如如果你设计了某些东西，我记得在我职业生涯的早期，我们拥有的软件中有一个报告系统，你可以添加这些被称为类别报告（category reports）的东西。向任何在 Axis 软件系统上工作的人致敬。我记得有一次我不得不添加一个嵌套类别报告。我不知道当时代码是否好，因为我当时在职业生涯中还太早。但我记得我知道我必须对多个报告多次这样做。所以我做的方式是，我做了大量的预先工作，不仅是为了把这一个东西生搬硬套进去，而是记住我必须这样做很多次。所以第一次的时候做了大量的工作。
But then subsequent times, right. It was very, very easy to just like make a couple surgical changes, Bada bada boom, everything worked. And yeah, like, there's no good way of, how do you, how do you quantify
但接下来的几次，对吧，只要做一些外科手术式的改动，啪嗒啪嗒，一切就都正常运转了，这非常非常容易。而且，是的，没有一个好方法来，你怎么，你怎么去量化
the, like, ease of extending a system? Like, there's no, because every system is going to be completely different. Like, extensibility of a system is completely defined by, like, what kind of system you're building.
系统的可扩展性，比如说？没有，因为每个系统都完全不同。系统的可扩展性完全取决于你正在构建什么样的系统。
There's no, there's no, like, a script you can write that's going to, like, assess. You have built a very, a very, like, right? It's not,
没有什么，没有什么脚本可以让你编写来评估。你已经构建了一个非常，非常，对吧？它不是，
it's much less measurable, right? it's exactly but it does correlate with the idea of software design right so the design of systems being this kind of separable idea from the implementation right it correlates with the idea of like you know a hallmark of good structural quality is having good APIs well what do we mean by good APIs it's it's a good design it's one that can be composed and is appropriately abstracted it's one that doesn't do unexpected things when you start putting different parts together, right? And it's not, you know, it's not really about the implementation at that level, you know, implementation and correctness and, you know, performance are things we can measure below that level. But at the level of the API, it's much more.
它没那么容易衡量，对吧？确实如此，但它确实与软件设计的理念相关，对吧？因此，系统设计与实现是这种可分离的概念，对吧？它与以下观念相关：良好结构质量的一个标志是拥有好的API。那么我们所说的好的API是什么意思呢？它是一个好的设计，是一个可以组合且经过适当抽象的设计，是一个当你开始将不同部分组合在一起时不会产生意想不到结果的设计，对吧？而且，你知道，它在那个层面上并不真正关乎实现，你知道，实现、正确性和性能是我们可以在该层面以下衡量的事情。但在API的层面上，它远不止于此。
Right now, there are some things like, you know, performance arguably is a feature of an API, or at least it is possible to write APIs which preclude the best performance, right? And it's possible to write other APIs which are more sympathetic to performance. But I think even there, we're talking more about, it's more like efficiency versus performance, right? If we can say efficiency is not doing extra work and performance is doing the work you have to do as quickly as possible, right? So performance is more of an implementation concern. Efficiency is an API concern, perhaps. Yeah, absolutely.
现在，有些事情，比如性能可以说是API的一个特征，或者至少有可能编写出排除了最佳性能的API，对吧？并且编写其他对性能更友好的API也是可能的。但我认为即便在那里，我们讨论的更多是效率与性能的区别，对吧？如果我们能说效率是不做额外的工作，而性能是尽可能快地完成你必须做的工作，对吧？因此，性能更多是一个实现方面的问题。效率或许是一个API层面的问题。是的，绝对是。
That sounds like a, I mean, none of these talks are out, right? Not yet, no. Yeah, they're going to, but anyways, as always, we always talk about these talks, and then I'm sure a few of the listeners go and check. We will have links that link to nothing while the talks are not available. And then either I check sporadically or sometimes someone will message me on their choice of social media platform saying, oh, the talks are up, you can link them now. So we will be sure to link to these when they are out.
听起来像是个，我的意思是，这些演讲都还没发布，对吧？还没，没有。是的，它们会发布的，但无论如何，像往常一样，我们总是谈论这些演讲，然后我确信会有一些听众去查看。在演讲发布之前，我们会提供指向空内容的链接。然后要么是我偶尔去查看，要么有时会有人在他们选择的社交媒体平台上给我发消息说，哦，演讲发布了，你现在可以放链接了。所以我们一定会确保在它们发布时提供这些链接。
Yeah, well, there are a couple of papers I would like to point you to, Conner, that came across my feed, and I sent them to Michael while he was making his talk. and, you know, they are really important, I think. So I think back in February or March, so it's a fairly recent paper, a researcher, I assume, her name is Margaret Ann Story, she's at the University of Victoria, Canada. She published a paper that's called
是的，康纳，有几篇论文我想向你推荐，它们出现在我的信息流里，我在迈克尔做演讲时把它们发给了他。而且，你知道，我认为它们真的很重要。所以我想大概在二月或三月，这是一篇相当新的论文，我猜这位研究人员的名字叫玛格丽特·安·斯托里（Margaret Ann Story），她在加拿大维多利亚大学。她发表了一篇名为
From Technical Debt to Cognitive and Intent Debt, and the subtitle is Rethinking Software Health in the Age of AI. But the sort of taxonomy here, of debt is what's really interesting, right? So technical debt is a term we're familiar with. It tends to be, we call it debt, but it's not really debt in a finance sense because, you know, in the financial debt is a tool
《从技术债到认知债和意图债》，副标题是《人工智能时代的软件健康重思》。但这里的分类法，即关于债务的分类，才是真正有趣的地方，对吧？技术债是我们熟悉的一个术语。它往往被称为债务，但它在金融意义上并不是真正的债务，因为，你知道，在金融中债务是一种工具
that, you know, like you can use. That is much less the case when we talk about technical debt. We think of it as just a bad thing. Now occasionally if you have, you know, occasionally if you're a startup and you want to ship really fast, you might make a, you might make a definite decision to take on technical debt. But by and large, it's something we try to avoid as engineers, right? Anyway, so technical debt is well known.
你可以使用，你知道的。当我们谈论技术债时，情况就没那么符合了。我们认为它纯粹是一件坏事。现在，如果你是一个初创公司，想要极快地发布产品，偶尔你可能会做出一个明确的决定来承担技术债。但总的来说，这是我们作为工程师尽量避免的东西，对吧？无论如何，技术债是众所周知的。
Technical debt is, you know, to distill it to something very simple, we could say it's a software system that has technical debt is harder to change, right? So it's some kind of, you know, just to say it very simply at a higher level, we could say technical debt correlates with ability to, or lack of ability. to change the software. Okay, so it's a thing that exists in the software, in the code. Whereas cognitive debt, cognitive debt talks about the team who built the software and their understanding of the code, right?
技术债，你知道的，把它精简成非常简单的东西，我们可以说，一个存在技术债的软件系统会更难修改，对吧？所以它某种程度上，简而言之，在更高层面上我们可以说技术债与修改软件的能力（或缺乏能力）直接相关。好吧，所以它是存在于软件中、代码中的东西。而认知债，认知债谈论的是构建软件的团队以及他们对代码的理解，对吧？
The code can work, but also the team might be losing understanding of how it works. That's cognitive debt, and it lives inside people, right? And we see that, you know, as people leave the team, they take with them the cognition and they might increase the cognitive debt, you know, in particular, if they had ownership over one piece and they leave, then the knowledge about how that piece works is now leaving with them, or at least some of it is, right? And then the third kind of debt is intent debt. This is arguably the most important kind of debt of all. And this is the, this is the knowledge about why we made those decisions in building the software, right? Why does the software work this way? Not, not, it's different
代码可以运行，但同时团队可能正在失去对其工作原理的理解。这就是认知债，它存在于人们的头脑中，对吧？我们看到，随着人员离开团队，他们带走了认知，并可能会增加认知债，你知道的，特别是如果他们对某一部分拥有所有权然后离职了，那么关于那部分如何工作的知识现在就随他们一起离开了，或者至少有一部分是这样的，对吧？然后第三种债务是意图债。可以说这是所有债务中最重要的一种。这就是关于我们在构建软件时为什么要做出这些决策的知识，对吧？为什么软件要这样工作？不，不是，它与技术债不同
from tech debt, obviously. It's different from cognitive debt in the sense that it is not really thinking about how the software works and how we understand it, but it's talking about why did we write it that way in the first place. What problem were we solving? And what are the problems today? and are they the same, right? And that is very difficult to fix if you lose, right? That is typically on many teams that is held by a couple of people who've been on the team a long time and they're the people you go to to ask about things, right? Why are we doing it this way?
显然不同。它不同于认知债的地方在于，它并非真正思考软件如何工作以及我们如何理解它，而是讨论我们当初为什么要这样编写它。我们当时在解决什么问题？今天的问题是什么？它们是一样的吗，对吧？如果你失去了这些，那是极难修复的，对吧？在许多团队中，这通常掌握在团队中呆了很长时间的几个人手里，他们就是你遇到事情时去询问的人，对吧？我们为什么要这么做？
You know, tell me if this is ringing true. You've worked on teams like this where, you know, you've had questions like, why do we this? I'll go ask Alice or go ask Bob, right? They've been here because they've worked here for 10 years. is they remember they know. And so the paper is really interesting because one of the observations is you can you can fix technical debt, right? You can fix technical debt if you don't have cognitive debt, right? Or at least it's easier to, right? And also you can fix cognitive debt to some
你知道的，看看这听起来是否真实。你曾在这样的团队工作过，在那里你会有这样的疑问，为什么我们要这样做？我去问爱丽丝或者去问鲍勃，对吧？他们一直都在这里，因为他们在这里工作了10年。他们记得，他们知道。所以这篇论文非常有趣，因为其中的一个观察结果是：你可以修复技术债，对吧？如果你没有认知债，你就可以修复技术债，对吧？或者至少这更容易，对吧？你也可以在某种程度上修复认知债
extent if you don't have intent debt, right? But it's very, very difficult to fix intent debt. and we see these kind of macro level ideas playing out in teams right how many times for instance have you seen or indeed how in terms of yourself have you yourself rewritten something so you could understand it you know here's some subsystem personally wrote it has left the company or moved on i've taken it over what am i going to do i'm going to try and understand it how am i can understand it. I'm going to rewrite parts of it. You know, it happens like every day. We see it when, when, when teams hand over projects that they built to other teams, right? This happens sometimes. This is in the paper as well, I think. Team A builds some library,
如果你没有意图债，对吧？但是意图债是非常非常难以修复的。我们看到这些宏观层面的理念在团队中上演，对吧？例如，你有多少次看到过，或者就你自身而言，你是否曾为了理解某事而亲自动手重写过代码？你知道，这里有一些子系统，原作者已经离职或调走了，我接手了它。我要怎么做？我要试着去理解它。我要怎么去理解它？我要重写它的某些部分。你知道，这几乎每天都在发生。当团队将他们构建的项目移交给其他团队时，我们会看到这种情况，对吧？有时会发生这种事。我想论文里也提到了这一点。A团队构建了一些库，
some software. They know it intimately, right? They've been involved in building it. They spent a year, two years, whatever, building the software. They know about all the intent, all the cognition. But then, you know, they move on to a different project, they move, they hand the project to another team who wants to take it forward, maintain it, maybe add some things in future. There is only one way that really works, which is if you have a long period of overlap during which the new team can work hand in glove with the old team and ask whatever questions they need to until the knowledge is transferred, right? That is the only way I've really seen that ever work.
一些软件。他们对其了如指掌，对吧？他们参与了它的构建。他们花了一年、两年或其他时间来构建这个软件。他们了解所有的意图和所有的认知。但随后，你知道的，他们转向了不同的项目，他们将项目移交给另一个想要推进、维护它或未来可能添加一些功能的团队。真正起作用的方法只有一种，那就是如果你有一个很长的重叠期，在此期间新团队可以与老团队密切合作，提出他们需要的任何问题，直到知识完全转移，对吧？这是我真正见过的唯一行之有效的方法。
And so those are the kind of macro level things that play out as a result of these ideas of tech debt versus cognitive debt versus intent debt. It's a very interesting kind of taxonomy. And, you know, the, so the subtitle of the paper is talking about AI in the age of AI. And it's making the point that, you know, these things are all still important, right? And AI actually runs the risk of increasing these debts, these debts in these three buckets. Maybe if we can control tech debt, that's one thing. And we can maybe do that a little more. But AI really can't touch cognitive debt or intent debt at the moment, apart from increasing them, of course.
所以，这些就是技术债与认知债与意图债这些理念所带来的宏观层面的影响。这是一种非常有趣的分类法。而且，你知道，论文的副标题提到了AI，即在AI时代。它指出，你知道，这些事情仍然都很重要，对吧？而且AI实际上有可能增加这些债务，即这三个类别中的债务。也许如果我们能控制技术债，那是一回事。我们或许可以稍微多做一点。但除了增加认知债和意图债之外，AI目前实际上根本无法触及它们。
AI can't. Connor is looking very thoughtful. right the way in which we use AI at the moment overwhelmingly cannot because cognition lives in the minds of humans
AI做不到。康纳看起来若有所思。对的，我们目前使用AI的方式在绝大多数情况下是无法做到的，因为认知存在于人类的头脑中，
and intent that also lives somewhat in the minds of humans and lives in things like design documents and things that capture why decisions were made and if we're using AI just to implement features, generate code as a glorified
意图债在某种程度上也存在于人类的头脑中，并且存在于诸如设计文档以及记录为什么做出决策的事物中。如果我们使用AI仅仅是为了实现功能、生成代码作为美化版的
auto-complete yeah, we can review the code it produces, we can make sure as far as we can that the technical debt stays low. But these other two kinds of debt, it's not really speaking to that. They require a different strategy. I mean, well, first I'll say that this is, it is very interesting. I've never thought about cognitive debt or intent debt. And my main thought was it kind of dovetails with the piece of advice from some technical book or something that I've read at one point that says, you know,
自动补全，是的，我们可以审查它生成的代码，我们可以尽最大努力确保技术债保持在较低水平。但另外这两种债务，它并没有真正解决。它们需要不同的策略。我的意思是，首先我要说这非常有趣。我从未想过认知债或意图债。我的主要想法是，它与我以前读过的某些技术书或其他地方的一条建议完美契合，那条建议说，你知道，
a comment should say why, not how. You know, the how should be in the code. But the comment should say, this is the motivation or the reason for why we're doing it. And if the why is obvious, then you don't really need to comment. Your code should be written in a way that, you know, because some people consider comments like an anti-pattern if you've written a code in a way that, like, you know, the best code is self-describing.
注释应该说明原因，而不是过程。你知道，过程应该在代码里。但注释应该说明我们为什么要这样做的动机或理由。如果原因显而易见，那么你其实就不需要注释。你的代码应该以这样一种方式编写，你知道，因为有些人认为注释是一种反模式，如果你编写代码的方式使得，你知道的，最好的代码是自解释的。
But a lot of the time... It's certainly an ideal maybe to strive for. Everything is, of course, imperfect. So, you know, as much as we can strive for that, we never actually achieve that goal. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Anyway, so that was my thought. Your comment saying that AI can't touch, I mean, my first thought was that sometimes potentially the intent is there in like the Git history of a code base, you know, it's there.
但很多时候……这当然是一个可以努力追求的理想。当然，一切都不完美。所以，尽管我们可以为此努力，但我们从未真正达到那个目标。是的，是的，是的。无论如何，这就是我的想法。你关于AI无法触及这些债务的评论，我的第一反应是，有时潜在的意图其实存在于代码库的Git历史中，你知道的，它就在那里。
It's just not at the top service level. And is, I mean, you know, this is, we should, we should, we should save part two of this conversation for updates on AI because I have been dying to talk to you, but then I, you know, I get the sense that you'd rather talk about other things. But now that, now that AI has come up, the door is open for me to walk through. Well, okay. But wait, we'll table that. Let's, yeah, let's finish the thread. We're on. Yeah, yeah. I mean, it dovetails with the idea, you know, that, was it Gerald Sussman who said, code should be written for humans to understand and only incidentally for computers to execute.
只是它不在最顶层的服务级别。而且，我的意思是，你知道的，我们应该把这场对话的第二部分留给关于AI的更新，因为我一直渴望跟你聊聊，但后来我，你知道的，我感觉你更愿意谈论别的事情。但既然AI已经被提出来了，我就可以顺理成章地推进了。好吧。不过等等，我们先搁置这个。是的，让我们把当前的话题说完。对，对。我的意思是，这与杰拉尔德·萨斯曼（Gerald Sussman）说过的一个观点不谋而合，那就是：代码应该为人类理解而编写，只是顺便让计算机执行。
I'm paraphrasing, but it was something of that nature. Yes, yeah. And there is a paper behind the paper, which is in the references, which is Peter Now's paper. It's called Programming as Theory Building. And it's a really interesting. So Peter Nower of, if you know the name, if you know Backers Now form, that's the same person.
我是用自己的话复述的，但大致就是这个意思。是的，是的。而且在这篇论文背后还有另一篇论文，就在参考文献里，那是彼得·诺尔（Peter Naur）的论文。它叫做《作为理论构建的编程》。这是一个非常有趣的观点。所以彼得·诺尔，如果你知道这个名字，如果你知道巴科斯-诺尔范式（Backus-Naur Form），那就是同一个人。
The idea, his idea in this paper, which is really interesting is that, A program is not the code. The code is an approximation. The program is the theory built in the heads of the team who build the program, right? And so this ties in with this idea of like, if one team or one person builds a program, it's very difficult for them to actually, one of the chief problems in programming is communicating the theory, right? because the code itself is a very imperfect communication of that of that theory which is the actual program
他的观点在这篇论文中非常有趣，那就是：程序并非代码。代码只是一种近似。程序是构建在构建该程序的团队头脑中的理论，对吧？因此，这与这样一种观点息息相关：如果一个团队或一个人构建了一个程序，他们要实际传达这个理论其实是非常困难的，对吧？因为代码本身对作为实际程序的那个理论的传达是非常不完美的。
other ways we have to communicate the theory include documentation diagrams maybe formulae things like that but they're all imperfect right the program is not any one of those things it's not even the code the program is the idea the theory in the head of the people who wrote it I have I've never heard that. And, I mean, my initial thought is that is surprising, kind of. I mean, what's my, my thought is that if you can express precisely the program you want, once it's codified, that is infinitely better than like a description. Or I guess you're saying that, like, what lives in someone's head is the program, not necessarily. Yes.
我们用来传达该理论的其他方式包括文档、图表、公式或类似的东西，但它们全都不完美，对吧？程序并不是这些东西中的任何一个，甚至连代码都不是。程序是理念，是编写它的人脑中的理论。我从没听过这个说法。而且，我的第一反应是，这有点令人惊讶。我的想法是，如果你能精确地表达你想要的程序，一旦它被写成代码，那就会比描述要好无数倍。或者我想你是在说，像存在于某人脑海中的才是程序，不一定。是的。
like English and communicating that is also imperfect potentially. So the code is an expression of the program, but it's not the program, right? Because if it were, then it wouldn't be possible to replace parts of it, like replace an implementation with an equivalent implementation. The fact that we can do that kind of tells us that the code is not the program. This is like mind-bending. Good. philosophical
像英语以及对它的交流也是不完美的，潜在地。所以代码是程序的一种表达，但它不是程序，对吧？因为如果是的话，就不可能替换其中的部分，比如用等效的实现替换某个实现。我们能够做到这一点，在某种程度上告诉我们代码并不是程序。这太颠覆三观了。很好。哲学上的
the code is not the program and because you can replace parts with other parts different implementations that by then definition well it lends weight to the idea I think right it learns weights through the idea
代码不是程序，因为你可以用其他部分、不同的实现来替换部分，根据定义，这为这个观点提供了分量，我认为，对吧？这提供了分量
it lends it lends weight oh lends weight to the idea yeah well I don't know I can tell you that my brain is like pushing back visiparously being like what do you mean the the thing that execute, that is the, sure, like,
这提供了分量，哦，为这个观点提供了分量，对吧？嗯，我不知道，我可以告诉你，我的大脑正在激烈地抗拒，心想：“你这是什么意思？执行的那东西，那就是，当然，就像，
my brain is like, there's a little voice in my head right now that's saying, like, what are we talking about here? Like, sure, maybe it's what you can say that the code is a representation, but it is a better, you know, well, is it a better representation if, if coded correctly is, is, you know, a thing that can deterministically execute. Sure. Is that not better than like a? Well, let me ask you another question about your experience coding, right?
我的大脑就像，我脑海中现在有一个小声音在说，我们在说什么呢？当然，也许你可以说代码是一种表示形式，但它是一种更好的，你知道，好吧，如果编码正确，它是一种可以确定性执行的东西，难道它不是一种更好的表示形式吗？难道它不比一个？好吧，我来问你关于你编程经验的另一个问题，对吧？
you currently work on a code base. I'm going to guess, through no judgment, that some parts of it you consider to be better than others. Yes. I'm going to guess that right now, the thing you're working on, you will have perhaps a better idea of it in a week. You know, maybe a thing you're working on right now, you are struggling with parts of.
你目前在一个代码库上工作。我猜想，绝无贬意，其中的某些部分你认为比其他部分要好。是的。我猜想，你现在正在处理的事情，在一周后你可能对其有更好的理解。你知道，也许你现在正在处理的事情，你正在与其中的某些部分搏斗。
You have some parts of it down, other parts of you're still discovering. If this isn't quite happening today, then certainly is probably something that has happened to you. And it's a process of discovery of how it should be. And how it should be really is something that is fulfilling or solving a problem you have today. Right. And you might come to a point where you have sufficiently solved that problem.
你搞懂了某些部分，而其他部分你还在摸索中。如果今天情况不完全是这样，那这很可能也是曾经在你身上发生过的事情。这是一个探索它应该是什么样子的过程。而它应该是什么样子，确实是能够满足或解决你今天面临的问题的东西。对吧。而且你可能会达到这样一个点，即你已经充分解决了那个问题。
And then you say, that code's good. I'm going to leave that for a while. But then equally, you might wake up in a month, two months, and think, oh, you know, I remember that thing I was working on and now I see, with this other context, now I see how that could be solved much more easily or much differently or much more in some way that there's something that seems nicer, right?
然后你会说，那段代码不错。我先把它放着不管一段时间。但同样地，你可能会在一个月、两个月后醒来，然后心想，“哦，你知道吗，我记起了我一直在处理的那件事，现在我明白了，有了这个其他的背景，现在我明白了这个问题可以如何被更轻松、更不同、或者以某种更好、更完美的方式解决，”对吧？
And so the program, in a sense, is evolving inside your head and the code that's in the machine is always an imperfect representation of it. I mean, you are, well, it depends. It depends on, I think it depends. The gears turned in Connors head right now. I mean, there's like two different, there's many, what is it, the Walt Whitman, you know, multitudes. Yeah, yeah. Something is that there, within me, there's an APL programmer.
所以程序在某种意义上是在你的脑海中演进的，而机器中的代码永远是它的一种不完美表现。我的意思是，你，好吧，这得看情况。这取决于，我觉得它取决于。康纳的脑子里现在飞转着各种念头。我的意思是，这就像有两种不同的，有很多种，怎么说来着，用沃尔特·惠特曼的话说，就是“包含 multitudes（浩瀚自我）”。对，对。有种说法是，在我内心深处，住着一个 APL 程序员。
And to tell him that, you know, or her, in my case, it's a him, that, you know, always the code is an imperfect representation of the program is just false. I mean, Cadane's algorithm in BQN is, it's the most beautiful. It is perfect, in my opinion. well, I mean, could it be slightly improved on in a different language? Maybe. But it is the closest to like the epitome of beautiful, elegant. But that programmer is juxtaposed with a different programmer. Like when I started my career, once again, shout out to Axis, you know,
而告诉他，你知道的，或者她——对我和我的情况来说，是个“他”——总是认为代码是程序的不完美表现，这纯粹是错的。我是说，BQN 中的卡丹算法（Cadane's algorithm），它是最美的。依我之见，它是完美的。好吧，我是说，它有没有可能在另一种语言中得到些许改进？也许吧。但它最接近美丽和优雅的巅峰。不过，那个程序员与另一个程序员并存。比如，当我开始我的职业生涯时，再次向 Axis 致敬，你知道的，
multi-million dollar C++ code base, originally written in, I believe, basic and then ported it at one point back in the 90s. And so, you know, a ton of legacy code and technical debt. And absolutely, everything that you said, you know, of I'm trying to implement some feature that corresponds to some regulatory document passed by either the Canadian government or the U.S. federal or state government because in America, there's state-by-state insurance, you know, regulations. And so definitely, like, the program exists, I guess you could say, in the regulatory document and needs to be, you know, I don't know, visualized in your head and then how you're going to put that. And there's tons of things, like the limitation of my understanding of the system as it is. But, and so, yeah, I guess when I think about the person working in that large system who didn't even fully understand how the system work, 100%. You know, I do something, you know, at some point, a year later, I look back and I was like, what was I thinking?
一个价值数百万美元的 C++ 代码库，最初是用 Basic 编写的，然后在 90 年代又被移植回来。所以，你知道的，有大量的遗留代码和技术债务。当然，正如你所说的那样，我试图实现某个功能，它对应着加拿大政府或美国联邦或州政府通过的某个监管文件，因为在美国，各州都有各自的保险监管规定。所以毫无疑问，比如，程序存在于监管文件中，你可以这么说，它需要在你脑海中被具象化，然后考虑如何将其呈现出来。这里面有很多东西，比如我对现有系统理解的局限性。但是，所以，是的，我想当我想到那个在大型系统中工作、甚至没有完全理解系统如何运作的人时，100%。你知道的，我做了一些事，你知道的，在某个时刻，一年后回过头来看，我心想：我当时在想什么？
Like, there's obviously a better way to do this than the way that I did it at the time. But then when I, when I juxtapose that with, like, the code artist, if you will, that many people refer to me as, whenever, I start gushing about combinators and and glyphs. I really do think that like APL is an evolution of like mathematics and notation and that like one of my career goals and quests in life is to uncover, you know, I only, I think the notation that we have in mathematics is just like the beginning of, you know, like, what is it, what is it the guy that wrote the history of mathematical notation? Like we're only, we're only like, we're only like a fraction of the way.
就像，显然有比我当时采用的方法更好的方式来完成这件事。但当我把这与——如果你愿意这么叫的话——“代码艺术家”进行对比时，很多人在我开始滔滔不绝地谈论组合子（combinators）和符号（glyphs）时，都会这么称呼我。我真的认为 APL 就像是数学和符号体系的一次演进，我职业生涯的目标和追求之一，就是去发掘，你知道的，我只觉得我们在数学中拥有的符号，其实只是……你知道的，那个写数学符号史的家伙叫什么来着？就像我们才刚刚走完历史的一小段路程。
way through history, you know? It's going to change. 10 years, 100 years, a millennia. Will we be alive? Nobody knows, folks. Nobody knows if we're going to make it till then. But the point being is that I think that there is some like truth in some symbolic notation, whether that's APL or some evolved form or some extension of mathematical notation. That is like the purest, truest representation of some kind of thing. But I don't know. I'll stop talking and let you respond to what I've said, yeah. Well, let me ask you, I think one of the useful notions we can bring to bear here is the idea of self-similarity.
才走了一小段，你知道吗？它会改变的。10年，100年，或者一千年。我们还能活着吗？没人知道，伙计们。没人知道我们能不能活到那个时候。但重点在于，我认为某些符号表示法中蕴含着某种真理，无论是 APL 还是某种演进的形式，亦或是数学符号的某种扩展。那才是某种事物的最纯粹、最真实的表现。但我不说了，我闭嘴，让你来回应我刚才说的话，好吗？好吧，让我问你，我认为我们可以引入这里的有用概念之一，就是自相似性（self-similarity）的概念。
So, and I think what you said is to some extent true, but alongside the argument here, which is that programs, so programs are not usually this kind of ideal thing that you were talking about, like the, the mathematics. They are, they exist to solve some problems. they exist to do something, right? But the idea of self-similarity is one I want to talk about, because, you know, so remind me what Kadam's algorithm is, is that the... It's the mac, it goes by a couple different names,
所以，我觉得你刚才说的话在某种程度上是正确的，但与这里的论点并行的是，程序通常不是你刚才谈到的那种理想化的东西，比如数学。它们存在是为了解决某些问题。它们存在是为了做某些事情，对吧？但自相似性这个概念是我想要探讨的，因为，你知道的，提醒我一下，卡丹算法是什么，那是……它是那个，它有好几个不同的名字，
maximum subarray sum, given a negative positive integers. What's the contiguous array subarray that equals the largest sum? So, okay, so what are some applications of that? In other words, that's an algorithm. then what problem does it solve? For example. Oh, I'm sure it solves a bunch, but off the top of my head, I mean, I don't know. I'm not asking the question to be contrary, you understand.
最大子数组和，给定一组负数和正数。哪个是总和最大的连续子数组？所以，好吧，那它的应用有哪些呢？换句话说，这是一个算法。那么它解决的是什么问题？举个例子。哦，我确信它能解决很多问题，但就凭我的第一直觉，我是说，我不知道。我提问并不是为了抬杠，你懂的。
I'm like, I'm sure it has lots of applications. I'm just asking for examples. I don't know if the top I have. We can ask, what are some applications of Cadane's algorithm and computer vision used in 2D image process to find the brain? or most intense rectangular region in a bitmap financial analysis. Oh yeah, stock trading, you know. Okay, okay.
我只是觉得，我确信它有很多应用。我只是在索要一些例子。我脑子里一下子也想不出来。我们可以问，卡丹算法有哪些应用？比如计算机视觉中用于 2D 图像处理以寻找图像中最亮、或最强烈的矩形区域，或是金融分析。哦，对，股票交易，你知道的。好吧，好吧。
So the point here is, my point that I want to make is that, like, Cadan's algorithm is one implementation, and as you say, might be a very elegant one, but it's one implementation we found to solve these problems, right? But it's not necessarily the only implementation out there, right? And so the program is distinct from the algorithm that implements it, right? Man, this episode has some dead air. Don't worry, we've got a single button, truncate silence. Oh, it's going to make it look like Connor has all the answers all, like, just like that.
所以这里的重点是，我想表达的观点是，卡丹算法只是一种实现，正如你所说，这可能是一种非常优雅的实现，但这是我们为解决这些问题而找到的一种实现，对吧？但这并不一定是唯一的实现，对吧？所以程序不同于实现它的算法，对吧？天哪，这期节目里有些冷场。别担心，我们有一个一键消除静音的功能。哦，这会让人觉得康纳无所不知，轻而易举就搞定一切。
Well, is that the goal or is the goal just not to waste the listener's time of, every once in a podcast, there's like such a large gap. I'm like, did my podcast crash or something? And that's at like 2.3 times X. The program is separate from the implementation. So, like, so Cadain's algorithm is a solution to finding the maximum sub-array sum. And you're saying that that implementation, because Cadain's algorithm is a specific implementation. Sure. And if your problem is maximum sub-ray sum, it's a great algorithm.
好吧，这真的是我们的目标，还是说我们的目标只是为了不浪费听众的时间？在播客中，有时会有这么长的空白期。我甚至会想：我的播客是不是崩溃了？而且那还是在 2.3 倍速播放的时候。程序与实现是分开的。所以，比如，卡丹算法是寻找最大子数组和的一种解决方案。而你的意思是，那个实现——因为卡丹算法是一种具体的实现。没错。如果你的问题是最大子数组和，那它就是一个极好的算法。
If your problem, and again, the idea is self-similarity, right? Yes, it's a good way to solve maximum subray sum. Is maximum subrace sum a good way to solve the problem above it? In the case of vision or finances or the applications you mentioned, yes. Okay. But it's not. So the idea of self-similarity is like, if I can draw another example, right? If we think about, you know, when we were talking to Sean, the idea of in-place,
如果你的问题——再次强调，这个概念就是自相似性，对吧？是的，这是解决最大子数组和的好方法。那么最大子数组和是解决它上一层问题的好方法吗？在视觉、金融或你提到的那些应用场景中，是的。好吧。但事实并非如此。所以自相似性的概念就像是，如果我能再举一个例子，对吧？如果我们想想，你知道的，当我们和肖恩交谈时，关于原地（in-place）的概念，
sort, in place stable sort, right? that is that before you know 30 years ago that was a research problem about 30 maybe 35 years ago but it was one of Steppenoff's great contributions to the field of algorithms right and and the point is that like there is no level one of the points that I made in my talk or one of my talks recently I forget which one now there is no level below which abstraction fails right There is no distinction between application code versus library code. There should be no idea of like, here's a boundary at an API level below which we hide all of the difficulties and complexity. Right.
排序，原地稳定排序，对吧？这就是在——你知道的，30 年前，那还是一个研究课题，大约 30 年前，也许 35 年前，但那是斯捷潘诺夫（Stepanov）对算法领域的伟大贡献之一，对吧？关键在于，就像我在演讲中或者最近的某个演讲中提到的那样——我记不清具体是哪一个了——没有哪个层级是抽象会失效的，对吧？应用代码和库代码之间不应该有什么区别。不应该存在这样一种观念，即在某个 API 级别存在一条分界线，我们在它之下隐藏了所有的困难和复杂性。对吧。
No, everything is self-similar as we go down. We build one API in terms of the next. With the result that when we get to the very bottom, frequently things just don't only become less complex. They just disappear. Right. And so stable salt is built on stable. partition is built on rotate, is built on reverse, is built on itter swap, right? Range swap.
不，当我们向下深入时，一切都是自相似的。我们基于前一个 API 构建下一个 API。其结果是，当我们到达最底层时，往往不仅复杂性减少了，它们甚至直接消失了。对吧。所以稳定排序（stable_sort）是建立在稳定分区（stable_partition）基础上的，稳定分区是建立在旋转（rotate）基础上的，旋转是建立在反转（reverse）基础上的，反转又是建立在交换迭代器（iter_swap）基础上的，对吧？还有范围交换（range_swap）。
It's abstractions all the way down. And when you get to the bottom, the abstraction, you know, the complexity disappears. Isn't at the bottom like ones and zeros? Uh, no? No? I'm going to say no. What's at the bottom? I don't know.
这就是一路到底的抽象。而当你到达底层时，抽象的……你知道的，复杂性就消失了。难道最底层不就是 1 和 0 吗？呃，不是吗？不是吗？我要说：不是。那最底层是什么？我不知道。
What? We don't know. Like, like, we arbitrate. rarely choose to make the bottom where it is. Yeah, it's convenient for us to to make hardware that deals in binary, right? And so that in a sense is the practical bottom for us right now. But, but that isn't the theoretical bottom, right? That doesn't mean that abstraction runs out at some level. Yeah, ultimately we live in a physical world. I mean, ultimately those ones and zeros, you think a nice, good-looking ones and zeros
什么？我们不知道。比如，比如，我们进行仲裁。我们很少会刻意把底层定义在它现在的位置。是的，对我们来说，制造处理二进制的硬件很方便，对吧？所以在某种意义上，这可以说是我们目前的实际底层。但是，这并不是理论上的底层，对吧？这并不意味着抽象在某个层级就会用尽。是的，归根结底我们生活在一个物理世界中。我的意思是，归根结底那些 1 和 0，你以为那些整齐美观的 1 和 0
are really mushy waveforms down deep in the hardware somewhere they're not like, they don't have straight line edges. Oh man. Have you been reading some like deep philosophical books lately? Or this is like... No, no.
在硬件深处的某个地方，其实是极其混乱的波形，它们可没有笔直的边缘。天哪。你最近是不是在读一些深奥的哲学书？还是说这只是……没有，没有。
I've just been working in embedded. So let's take a step back here because I feel like my ice cream sandwich for lunch was not substantial enough food for my brain to operate at the level that you're, is operating at right now. So, I mean, we're talking about the paper. And then at some point, we were talking about how the code is not the program.
我只是在做嵌入式开发。所以我们在这里退一步，因为我觉得我午餐吃的冰淇淋三明治提供的能量还不够，不足以让我的大脑以你目前正在运转的水平来思考。所以，我的意思是，我们一直在谈论那篇论文。然后在那之后的某个时候，我们一直在讨论代码为何不是程序。
The program lives inside our head. Yeah. Programming as theory building. Yeah. And then abstraction and self-similarity. And what does all this mean? It means, I don't know. It means that...
程序存在于我们的脑海中。对。编程即理论构建。对。还有抽象和自相似性。所有这一切意味着什么？这意味着，我不知道。这意味着……
Well, the meaning is what we give it, right? we build things, hopefully to make the world a better place. But if these kind of quality ideas are important to us, then these ideas should come along for the ride and should be the way we think about things, I think. And so I guess, yeah, taking a massive step back, it was that AI can't help with cognitive debt and intent debt. And I guess that's why we started talking about this
嗯，意义是我们赋予它的，对吧？我们构建事物，希望让世界变得更美好。但如果这些类型的优质理念对我们很重要，那么这些想法就应该一并前行，并成为我们思考问题的方式，我认为是这样的。所以我想，是的，退一大步来看，AI 无法解决认知债务（cognitive debt）和意图债务（intent debt）。我想这就是我们开始讨论这个话题的原因
is because if the program lives in our head and we're doing some level of job, you know, to the extent that the best is a perfect job, you know, sometimes it's a good job, sometimes it's a bad job of encoding the program that lives in our head into your programming language of choice. But, you know, there's a certain amount of cognitive debt that will exist and an intent debt that will exist. And AI is never really going to help peering into people's heads to get the actual. essence of the program.
因为如果程序存在于我们的脑海中，而我们正在做某种程度的工作——在最好的情况下是一项完美的工作，你知道的，有时是一项不错的工作，有时是一项糟糕的工作——将存在于我们脑海中的程序编码为你所选的编程语言。但是，你知道的，必然会存在一定量的认知债务和意图债务。而 AI 永远无法真正通过窥探人们的头脑来获得程序的真实本质。
Something like that. My course? I don't know. You're close. I mean, let's not say, let's not talk in absolutes here. Let's not say flat that AI cannot help. Let's rather say that the way we are using AI right now tends towards increasing cognitive debt and increasing intent debt and increasing technical debt, although we have a better
差不多是这样。我的理解对吗？我不知道。你很接近了。我的意思是，咱们别把话说得太绝对。别断言 AI 绝对帮不上忙。我们不如这样说：我们目前使用 AI 的方式，往往会导致认知债务增加、意图债务增加以及技术债务增加，尽管我们可能更清楚
idea, perhaps, of how to keep a rain on that one. people aren't talking a lot about the cognitive debt and intent debt but I think they are really important okay I feel like I'm back on you know you might be on a very nice yacht and I'm now back on my raft I was in the ocean and I scramble back on the raft and so now now I guess my my question that would I would ask is that if and because I agree that the use of these AI tools is increased increasing cognitive and intent debt. But did people say the same thing back when like C was invented? And people stopped coding an assembly and then people stopped understanding assembly
如何控制住后者。人们并没有过多地讨论认知债务和意图 debt，但我认为它们确实非常重要。好吧，我觉得我又回到了……你知道的，你可能在一艘非常漂亮的游艇上，而我现在回到了我的木筏上。我刚才在大海里，然后连滚带爬地回到了木筏上。所以现在，我想我要问的问题是，如果——因为我确实认为这些 AI 工具的使用增加了解认知债务和意图债务。但在当年 C 语言被发明的时候，人们不也说过同样的话吗？当时人们停止使用汇编语言编程，然后人们就不再理解汇编语言了
because you could make the same argument that there was more cognitive debt. I'm not sure about the intent debt, but that people didn't understand that lower level as well. But did it matter at the end of the day? Okay. So there are two different things here. One is, I think, that the arguments around or the taxonomy of technical debt, cognitive debt, intent debt, I think stands apart from AI, right? The subtitle of the paper is like AI might be worsening these things, but I think that idea really stands apart, right? Before we had it, and before we had AI, we could have talked about the same kind of things and identified the same issues, right?
因为你完全可以说，当时产生了更多的认知债务。我不确定意图债务是不是也这样，但人们确实没有以前那么理解底层了。不过从长远来看，这重要吗？好吧。这里有两件不同的事。一件事是，我认为关于技术债务、认知债务、意图债务的论点或分类，本身是独立于 AI 存在的，对吧？那篇论文的副标题类似于“AI 可能会使这些情况恶化”，但我认为这个核心概念确实是独立存在的，对吧？在我们拥有这些工具之前，在我们拥有 AI 之前，我们本就可以讨论同样的事情并识别出相同的问题，对吧？
So there's that. So I think that stands alone as an idea. the other to your question right the eternal question of when a new technology comes along it causes atrophy of skills right and and this is just basically true so the question really is so like you know if you if you doubt that's true try and take a high school math paper from 1890 or whatever and you'll find it very difficult i'm sure so it's just in some sense true but the question really is like, does it matter, as you said? And that is a question that, you know, I think, I don't think, I think everyone needs to find
所以情况就是这样。因此我认为作为一个独立的概念，它站得住脚。至于你的问题，对吧？——当一项新技术出现时，它会导致技能退化，这是一个永恒的问题，对吧？这基本上是事实。所以真正的问题在于，你知道的，如果你怀疑这是真的，试着去做一份 1890 年代的高中数学试卷之类的内容，我确信你会发现它非常难。所以在某种意义上这确实是真的，但真正的问题就像你说的，这重要吗？这是一个我认为……我不认为，我认为每个人都需要找到
their own answer to that question because there is still value in having those skills. And in a world where people tend not to have those skills, there is even more value as an individual in having them sometimes. Interesting. So, in other words, you think the answer potentially is different for people on an individual basis. Yeah, I think people just need to decide, you know, what, what path they want their life to take in that sense. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts,
他们自己对这个问题的答案，因为拥有这些技能仍然是有价值的。而在一个人们往往不具备这些技能的世界里，个人拥有这些技能有时反而更有价值。有趣的是。所以，换句话说，你认为这个问题的答案对每个人来说可能是因人而异的。是的，我认为人们只需要决定，你知道的，他们希望自己的人生走上一条什么样的道路。请务必查看这些节目shownotes，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是访问 ADSP thepodcast.com，这里有我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下你的想法、
comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反大括号（anti-brace）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。